here's a big one if you're not feeling
it find new friends I'm being dead
serious about this this one is real big
for me who you hang out with is a huge
deal and again these are all tried and
true things right we've heard the you're
the whatever of the five friends you
spent like that's real that's that one
put in the bank like if you're not
feeling it you need to go to meetup.com
and go to 10 meetups of people that are
hungry like it's unbelievable what
happened to me when I got into the
Silicon Valley world and started meeting
like Mark Zuckerberg and like EV
Williams and sock and like Travis like
it changed my life this town actually
it's fun for me to tell the story here
South by Southwest 2007 changed my life
because I hung out I forced myself to go
to a Web 2.0 which later became social
media the current state of the internet
conference South by Southwest and I was
looking at all these kids and by the way
this is when Tech wasn't cool straight
nerds but they were trying to change
they weren't here for kicks and Giggles
they weren't here to hook up they were
here to like change the world like I'm
I'm going to build a product that is
going to be in every single person's
hand like and they have like the
twitters and the Facebooks the Ubers
they did and it was the biggest impact
of my career and it's something I think
a lot about now if you feel motivated by
this conversation or you're intrigued by
it and one new winner friend like you
know what I mean add one new winner
friend and cut one loser friend like
yeah I know he's been your boy since
fourth grade but he sits at home and
smokes weed and plays 2K all day
like you can only love them so much go
home cut one cut your loserous loser
friend and go find a winner friend Go to
meetup.com go to a Facebook group join
some it's unbelievable to watch my team
like they get faster they get smarter
they get more confident right it's real
man it's real confidence and like hunger
gets passed on to each other it's like
Team Dynamics it's why like a great
player that sucks can team up like go
audit your circle add one more winner
decrease one more loser hey it's Evan
Carmichael and I make these videos
because when I started my first business
I I really struggled to believe myself I
was making 300 bucks a month and quit on
my business partner and the thing that
saved me was watching the stories of
successful entrepreneurs they gave me
strategies as well as hope and belief
that just maybe I could do it myself as
well and I hope that this video here
today helps you get a little bit more
belief in yourself because I still need
the videos for myself today too so today
let's learn how you can make new friends
enjoy
[Music]
rule number two is shift your thinking
with Mel Robbins this question from
Alana is one that we get a lot and it's
all about uh friendships and when your
life changes and your friendships change
how to deal with it Alana is working on
herself she writes as I leave the old me
behind I'm scared of the rejection I
will face when I start making choices
for the new me for example instead of
going to happy hour to and moan
about problems and having retail therapy
sessions spending money I don't have
I'll choose to go to the gym or go home
to spend time on my project to fulfill
my dreams how can I cope with losing
friendships that the old me has you know
what's interesting is that Alana said in
her opening sentence to me I'm scared of
the rejection I will face when I start
making choices for the new me you know I
read something interesting and I want to
tell you this before I forget it and
then I'm going to talk generally about
friendship hoping that the way that I'm
thinking about friendship will help you
lose the guilt now number one
um this kind this came from a book that
my husband was reading about alcohol and
it really made me stop and think and
that is this when you decide that you
don't want to drink for whatever reason
what's interesting about being somebody
that doesn't drink at a party is that
the only person that gives us what's in
your glass is you nobody else typically
cares but the thing that's interesting
is that when somebody says to you would
you like a drink and you say no I'm not
drinking I'm not drinking for the month
of January or no I'm sober or not you
know I don't feel like it what happens
is the fact that you're turning down the
alcohol it can actually magnify somebody
else's struggle with their own decisions
around it and so the first thing that I
want to point out is if you have friends
that make you wrong for changing your
life for the better that's their issue
it's not yours and so you gotta untangle
the fact that they have baggage about
getting in shape or they have baggage
about going to the bar that's theirs and
it has nothing to do with the decisions
that you're making so if your friends in
general give you blowback for changing
for the better what you need to say in
the back of your mind is interesting
they're obviously very conflicted about
their choice to go to the bar and drink
every night but that has nothing to do
with me here's the other thing you can
do if they start to make you wrong you
can say well you want to go to Planet
Fitness with me instead it doesn't sound
like you want to be at the bar so that
said let me talk to you a little bit
about friends friends are people that
you care about and I have this test I
call it the funeral test if somebody in
your life were to die ask yourself would
I go to their funeral if the answer is
yes they're friend of yours that's the
test for whether or not in my opinion
someone is a friend because it means you
care about them now here's the other
thing about friendship that I want you
to understand you can care about
somebody and not like hanging out with
them and that's the situation that
you're in right now that you have plenty
of friends that you care about if they
were to die you would go to their
funeral if they needed you you would be
there if you saw them you'd be happy to
see them but you don't like to hang out
with them the other thing that I want
you to think about is that and that's
okay that's like a normal part of
friendship and the reason why that's a
normal part of friendship is because one
of the things that we know about life is
that you're always going to be changing
in the old pattern and the old chapter
you had certain patterns right in the
old chapter of your life you would go to
the bar and drink you would go to the
store and spend money you didn't have
you're in a new chapter now and so you
have different patterns when your life
takes on different patterns whether it's
you're no longer going to the bar you're
going to the gym the pattern might even
be that one of your kids is playing with
a different soccer team or maybe you've
moved to a different street in your town
when the patterns change so will your
circle of friends it's a fact of life
but that doesn't mean your old friends
the ones that you used to drink with
aren't friends anymore it just means
that you don't want to hang out with
them you still care about them but you
don't like doing what they do the
patterns have changed for a long time I
had a lot of drama around this until I
realized that it's not personal it's not
personal that you don't want to hang out
with them patterns in your life have
simply changed the final thing that I
want to leave you with that may also
help you is that remember I've given you
the funeral test if you'd go to their
funeral they're definitely a friend it
means you care about them but you might
not like hanging out with them that much
and that's cool that's normal the other
thing that I want you to think about
when it comes to friendships is you can
typically put friends into three buckets
you got friends for a reason you got
friends for a season and you have
friends for a lifetime and one of the
interesting things that I know about my
own life is that as the patterns of my
life change so do the friends that I
hang out with more frequently and I also
believe that as you change and the
patterns in your life change people show
up in your life for a reason the right
people will show up when you start going
to the gym the right people that you
need for the pattern that you're in
right now will start showing up when
you're working on your project instead
of shopping and it's exactly the kind of
people that you need they're there for a
reason and the friends of yours that are
friends of yours for a lifetime I bet
you don't hang out with them that much
at all anyway but I bet they're the
first person that you call when you need
to talk to somebody about somebody
important those are the friends for a
lifetime and those folks that are still
sitting at the bar and love to blow
money that they don't have those were
friends for a season so if you're
wondering how to cope with feeling
guilty about distancing yourself and if
you're wondering how to stop feeling
like a bad and unloyal friend understand
this friendship it's really not about
you it's about the category in which
people fit in depending upon what
pattern and what chapter of your life
that you're in that's it like lose the
drama about it the friends at the bar
are friends for a season the people that
are going to show up when you start
going to the gym are friends for a
reason and the people that you need to
call whenever you've got a problem
they're friends for a lifetime and
they're always going to be there rule
number three is find a place to meet
people with Vanessa van Edwards now
let's talk about my 10 favorite spots to
meet new people again this is if you're
in a new city or you're in an old city
you need a little bit of a refresh
number one highly specialized events
a lot of the times people go to big
networking events where there's no
purpose or the only purposes Network and
they're so high pressure I would rather
you go to highly specialized events the
reason for this is because one you're
going to find your people you're going
to find people who are also attracted to
that same event and two it's going to
give you more to talk about at a
networking event you inevitably end up
with what do you do where are you from
have you been here before boring boring
boring boring at a highly specialized
event Renaissance Fair Comic-Con events
uh scrapbooking Fair book club about
vampires why a club non-profit charity
you love those are all really specific
and then you can talk about specific
things I want to give you a really
ridiculous specific example here so a
couple weeks ago I went to a train Expo
I know I'm really cool do a lot of cool
stuff on the weekends I was in a train
Expo because my daughter loves trains
and so we went we saw the little
miniature trains and I talked to people
in a lot of overalls and we rode a
little train and I was standing looking
at a giant miniature Train Exhibit and
someone next to me goes Vanessa I was
like Allison and it was my friend from
high school now we're both in a new city
but she was taking her kids to the train
Expo and we immediately bonded about how
much our kids love train our kids of the
same age our kids began to bond over
trains and now we're hanging out all the
time this was a highly specialized place
on a highly specialized topic and so I
was able to reconnect with the right
person with the kids of the same age as
mine and we have so much in common so I
want you to think about what's a highly
specialized event a fair a gathering a
charitable event where you're going to
meet like-minded people those are the
kind of events I want you to go to
seconds book clubs
so book clubs are really special because
you're learning together anytime you're
doing something together you're going to
forge deeper friendships a lot of the
time it's hard to forge new friendships
when you're just grabbing coffees you're
not actually doing something you don't
have shared goals in book clubs you have
first a shared goal everyone's trying to
read the same book at the same time and
then second you're learning together
you're discussing together you have lots
of topics to discuss so book clubs solve
two different problems one is it has a
shared goal so there's a reason to get
together and second it makes it really
easy to never have an awkward silence if
you can always talk about the book
you're never going to run out of things
to say so I want you to think what is
your favorite kind of book or your
favorite genre book or a book that
you're a type of book that you're
curious about can you join an existing
book club or can you start a book club
with people that you've been wanting to
join or start friendships with you can
even do this digitally or online a
virtual book club or you can join a book
club at a local event when I first moved
back to Los Angeles back when I was
really young let's print it was a really
long time ago I really love vampire
fiction
you know I'm just so cool you're
learning so much about me I really liked
vampire fiction and so I started a
vampire fiction book club no joke open
to the public posted on meetup.com and I
met super cool people we all dressed in
black we wore dark lipstick we talked
about vampires it was great I met some
of my closest friends third City tour
now hear me out on this one city tours
are great if you're new to a city but
they're also great if you're in an
existing City and I don't want you to
just do a regular City Tour I would
highly recommend doing specialized City
tours a lot of people don't realize that
there are all kinds of Unique city tours
like ghost tours architecture tours
historical walking tours Street Food
Tours food cart tours I want you to
think about and I want you to Google
search or look on Airbnb experiences
what kind of unique tours are in your
city one you might meet other new people
to your city two you're probably going
to meet the host of the tour who's
probably an extrovert where you can say
hey I'm new to this city or I'm old to
the city and I'm looking to meet new
people tell me what the cool places to
go are where where do you like to hang
out and that way you're not only seeing
a new part of your city but you're also
meeting a like-minded person because if
they're running an architectural
architectural tour and you're interested
in architecture that's your person for
language class
there is nothing like stumbling through
a new language with other people so I
have found so many of my closest friends
learning languages I learned Spanish in
high school then I learned French then I
learned Mandarin I met my husband
learning Mandarin he was a fellow
English speaker trying to learn Mandarin
and we bonded so quickly because one we
had a shared goal right remember that
shared goal we're learning together and
two we were fumbling and laughing and
having all these really halting
conversations in Mandarin and that
bonded us more than ever and we ended up
getting married so I have a soft spot
for language learning so think about is
there a language you'd like to learn
sign language Spanish French English
whatever you're trying to learn
hopefully you already know English or
else this video is gonna be really
boring and see if you can sign up for a
class not just an app so an app doesn't
help you meet new people but a class
really helps oftentimes with foreign
language they also have language social
hours where you could go and practice
your language at a bar or a concert at a
networking event that also give you
something specific to talk about so
think about trying to learn a language
and trying to practice people you never
know you might I meet your soul mate
five trivia nights okay this one is only
for you if you love trivia I would
definitely not recommend if you don't
like trivia you're not good at trivia to
go to a trivia night you're not going to
meet your people but if you love facts
you're really good at historical trivia
you're really good at Pop Culture trivia
trivia nights are a great way to meet
people especially because you'll often
join a team where you can meet people
who are already there and they're
looking for the same experience one
you're never around things to say
because there's trivia happening to your
meeting like committed people who are
interested in facts and data like you
and three it's in a casual setting so if
you're uncomfortable you could always
change tables change teams or take a
step back I love trivia nights for
people who love trivia I do not love
trivia I am terrible at trivia but I
know so many friends who've met their
best friends at trivia nights so this is
for you if you love facts 6. dance class
again if you like dance or you're
curious about dance this is a great one
for you the reason for this is because
what most people don't realize is a lot
of clubs especially salsa or line
dancing or swing dancing they'll have a
learning hour before the actual dancing
or the band starts this is a great way
to meet people because people are there
to learn and again you have a shared
learning goal so think about are you
interested in swing or salsa or line
dancing and could you look up a local
club or a local bar that has classes
before they actually play the music then
you're partnering up with people you're
switching around you're talking about
the salsa you're talking about the music
you're go getting a drink together
you're standing in line you're going to
the crowds it is a great way to mingle
very quickly with other like-minded
people and you do not have to be good at
this if you're a beginner you're going
to meet the most people so when I went
to do a salsa class and it was
incredible I had so much fun I was a
pure beginner and everyone was so kind
they were so helpful I met so many
interesting people and I found that
being the Newbie being a beginner
actually helped me meet more of those
new people so dance class especially if
you're feeling brave seven specific
Fitness class or gym so a lot of people
like to go to the gym to meet people and
that works if you're an extrovert you
know you can be we're next to someone or
lifting and be like hey bro what are you
lifting I don't do that I I don't go to
the gym to meet people because I am way
too ambroverted to meet people at the
gym however I have been able to meet
people at specific Fitness Gyms or
specific locations in your gym for
example the sauna the sauna is a great
way to meet people if you have a gym
that has one because people don't have
their earpods in usually you get kind of
sweaty and wet so it's pretty easy to
make some small talk bring up
conversation it's quiet it's warm it's
wet that's a little weird but it
actually does really help meeting people
or you can meet people at a specific
kind of fitness center like a racket
club or a golf club or a tennis club is
there a specific kind of fitness center
or class where you can learn a new skill
remember learning is always good and
meet similar like-minded people so Jim
is great if you're an extrovert but
specific Fitness class within that gym
or Asana or the pool if you're a little
bit nervous and want a reason to talk to
people eight volunteer work Beach
cleanup soup kitchen volunteering at a
pantry this is my favorite one because
you truly meet other kind like-minded
people I was able to volunteer at a
beautiful Soup Kitchen in Portland I met
so many incredible people other
volunteers people in charge of the
organization I highly recommend if there
is a cause that you're really passionate
about that is a wonderful way to have
something to talk about something to do
together a shared goal by creating
things together or doing it together or
having campaigns together it's a really
great way to have lots of conversation a
shared goal and also you meet the right
kind of people with the right kind of
mindset nine hiking or run clubs so I
love going on walks with people I find
that sometimes if you're trying to meet
new people and you're sitting in a
coffee shop it's too intimidating so I
would rather hike or walk I also know
that some of my friends have joined run
clubs they meet great people who are
right at their Pace they're training for
half marathons or training for marathons
so think about is there a hiking group a
hiking Club a nature walking club or a
run Club you can join where you're again
using a shared goal you're meeting
people with like-minded interests and
it's really easy to talk about what
you're doing running hiking jogging
climbing nature looking all those things
10 block parties so this is a really
good tip if you're willing to take the
plunge I know this is a little bit this
is a bigger one but whether you're in a
new city or Old City meeting your
neighbors many people who are right in
your neighborhood it becomes very easy
to slowly build up friendships we first
moved to our neighborhood I held a big
block party I just put out a bunch of
candy got some sodas gotta I think I
ordered a couple pizzas we actually
borrowed a bounce house and put up a
bounce house for the kids and I just
told everyone on our block hey we're
having a block party for a couple of
hours it was an incredible way to meet
our neighbors and it made it easier over
the next few months to slowly build up
relationships so I highly recommend if
you feel brave enough host your own
block party again this can happen if
you're new in a city or if you're old in
a city the idea of reaching out to your
neighbors is one of the best ways to be
close to the people who you're seeing on
a daily basis and it's always good to
know your neighbor I want to do a little
bonus one here which is offering public
advice or help one of my friends Maddie
she moved to a new city and she didn't
know anyone and she was moving to the
city and did all this research on buying
a new house and she discovered that
there was all these weird city
regulations and Insider tips and
strategies and things you should know
about neighborhoods she put everything
she learned buying in a house into a
little PDF and she put it up online for
free she put up on our Twitter for free
and she said hey this is a little PDF
that I used when I was buying a house if
it helps you go ahead and use it and
then come and take me out we'll meet for
tacos she found that she was able to
meet other like-minded people who were
moving to the new city who were looking
to buy a new house and who benefited
from her PDF she said that she has more
friends than she can handle simply from
offering that out there so I'd also say
if you have a piece of knowledge or
advice you have for people and you're
willing to share that and offer that
help that can also be a great way to
meet people because you're offering help
and they're coming to you and you're
meeting the right people based on the
help you're offering also to make sure
you're actually taking action after
watching this video I've designed a
special free worksheet just for this
video the worksheet will highlight all
the Lessons Learned in this video as
well as pull out our three favorite
learnings and quotes that will inspire
you to actually do something the
worksheet will also give you space to
write down what your key takeaways are
and your specific plan of action to make
sure you're getting results if you want
the worksheet designed specifically for
this video absolutely for free there's a
link in the description below go click
on it and start building the momentum in
your life and your business I'll see you
there rule number four is put yourself
in novel situations with Brendan
burchard your job is to go have
adventures in the world and put yourself
in new novel situations to discern what
you like
I'm sure many of you guys you get the
questions too from you know younger kids
and their you know teens or in their 20s
who ask you you know but I don't know
what my passions are and what do you
always say
go do stuff
like
passions and interests emerge
out of actions
not contemplations
so you don't just sit around contemplate
what am I passionate about and come up
with something you need to experience a
menu of the world a little bit and go oh
I like this just like I never knew I
like sushi I never sat in a room one day
in Montana and go I like sushi no I had
to go experience culinary from all over
the place and I went to a sushi place
I'm like
I'm a guy that likes sushi and now if
you hang out with me I'm like let's go
I'm passionate about sushi I never
thought in a room I'd be passionate
about sushi one day I had it and became
passionate about it you find your
passions by living an active life
when you don't have passions we just got
to get more menu in front of you this is
why you always growing your network and
your relationships to discern like a lot
of people hope their purpose just lands
on them like your purpose is found out
in the world
your purpose is found by living
and choosing how you want to live and
living a purposeful life and more
purpose shows up if you want deep
relationships with people you're going
to have to uncover
your passions
you have to express
those Passions
and you're gonna have to elicit their
passions
you know does anyone have a friend who
talks on and on and on about something
that you aren't passionate about at all
anyone out there
encourage them
keep listening
don't we all need friends like that
it's important
it's important for you to listen to
other people's passions and it's okay if
there isn't I have one friend that is so
passionate I mean insane like
otherworldly passionate about video
games
now I haven't played a video game in
I don't know I don't even know how to
use the controllers anyone else have
that here we go to your friend's house
and their kids pop out the video game
they hand it to you and you get this
controller and it's like a spaceship and
you don't even know what it does that's
me I don't know I don't know how to play
a video game I'm not interested in video
games at all like it's not even I'm not
even interested in it and I have this
friend we will go out and he will tell
me about video games for like 90 minutes
and I'm so interested
because that's his passion
when someone's talking passion you know
what you say tell me more
it doesn't have to be your passion stop
listening for what you want to be and
experience and who you are and honor and
see the other
their passions their ideas their goals
their concerns
That's How to Win Friends and Influence
People you knew I was coming after the
Dale Carnegie didn't you you knew I was
going to drop it in there I know you
knew I was going to give me some Dale
cartoons you have in here How to Win
Friends and Influence People let me
summarize the whole book
be interested in other people
it's like a 300 page book
five words describe it be interested in
other people
that's how you win friends and influence
people stop listening through the lens
of only your interests and your passions
and open up to hearing and encouraging
any listening when if you talk to me if
you and I go out I'm like this I'm just
like I'm just taking it in like keep
bringing it keep bringing it just shovel
it all my way keep bringing it and
you're like yeah but Brandon people
shovel their stuff on me I'm like nope
the bad stuff goes right over here the
good stuff goes right in here it's like
just keep bringing it like you if you
want to be a great friend you elicit
you elicit their passions
and I don't think people talk about
their passions enough
and obviously I'm a personal development
guy so I have a high opinion about this
oh my goodness I think it's so important
to be passionate and to be passionate
you have to experience the world
to elicit other people's passion you
have to talk about what they've
experienced in the world you learn their
stories listen to what interests them
you have to pull in the conversation
their passion their interests their
ideas I know I'm being really repetitive
here a little bit but I think we really
need a reset on this one a real reset
because if you think about your favorite
friends to be around at the parties
they're passionate it doesn't mean
they're extroverted it doesn't mean
they're extemporaneous speakers it just
means whatever is going on with them I
have a friend who just
I can't even believe this guy
he's like a he's a friend in a mentor
he's like 58 years old he every time he
talks he just looks at his shoes
and he's not loud
he's not clownish like me
he's just super internal and thoughtful
but everything he's so passionate about
what he's saying he just likes that he
just passion he barely moves he's just
passionate and just hearing he's back
he's his voice isn't bad he talks like
this well you know I just this so is so
important and and does not and you're
like I wanted to pop up a little bit but
he doesn't need to his passion is there
and I connect with him on that
you all follow passion rule number five
is learn to reciprocate what's what's
your approach with networking and how do
you view that first and then we'll kind
of expand from there because that's the
glue of everything we do the podcast is
is kind of one of our ways we do that
I'm curious how that plays into your
role as a human so networking networking
with building relationships with other
people in your space to that you could
have joint ventures or Affiliates or
that's right or yeah opportunities and
yeah well I'll tell you the way most
people screw it up right I'm an
introvert so you know the world is kind
of shut down right now and to me that's
fine because I usually stay home anyway
I don't like being around crowds if I go
to events I hide
um it's uh it's just you know people
don't realize that you know they see on
camera see on stage and think oh this
guy's such an extrovert like
um I've never had a business card in my
life like I don't hand out business
cards I don't say you should call me we
should Network here's here's what I'll
tell you how to do it wrong
try to try to get someone to partner
with you JV with you do an affiliate
with you before you get to know them
before you understand them or before you
did something with them and you just
you're everybody else do you know how
many messages I get a week or DMS we get
a week hey you should partner with me
you should promote my new thing hey if
you just went sent one email to your
list of three million people we'd make
millions together like I don't I swipe
right and delete every single one of
them right because there's they're
trying to start a relationship by before
we even know each other before we've
done anything and I have to tell you
some of the most important relationships
in my life and this write this word down
it's reciprocity
do something in advance for somebody and
expect nothing in return I don't know if
that's the exact definition of
reciprocity but that's mine like so many
people will do something for someone and
wait for it to come back like don't just
do things for the people that you'd love
to build a relationship with selflessly
and God Karma the universe whatever you
believe in rewards you and I know that's
a hard thing to really understand but
you must I've when I built my
relationship with Tony Robbins I reached
out and did something for him and his
company in advance I I was literally
thanking him from the video the audios I
listened to a decade earlier right I
didn't expect to do business with him I
didn't want anything I just want to say
thank you and here's a here's an olive
branch and I did things for his company
that I thought they were missing and all
of a sudden later on we met and we were
supposed to meet for a half hour we met
for a whole day we became dear friends
and now for a decade we we talk every
single day I mean right now we talk
every single day of our lives right but
it didn't start with hey tone I got this
real estate program that could make you
Millions and you should email for me
like that's how most people start it a
lot of people will start I mean I just
got a letter two weeks ago
um maybe a little bit longer than that
it's uh my wife a client of my wife's
husband
and he kept asking for my address and my
I said give them give them our address
and I know he wants to send some he sent
me his book
and a letter on how stupid I would be if
I didn't promote this great book oh boy
that's a good approach
and then a week later he literally had
his wife call my wife and say hey did
Dean get that gift why isn't he calling
there's lots of money to be made I'm
like are you effing kidding me like just
write a letter and say Hey Dean
think what you're doing is awesome
here's what I do if there's anything I
can do to help you ever let me know
that's a completely different
relationship that's reciprocity that's
doing something for someone so just know
when it comes to networking if you
really want to build a relationship if
it's not just you meet two minutes we
should do something you're doing
research and you know that if you two
aligned you could make money together
you can make impact together you could
help each other do the research find out
what they like right if if they're
having a baby have it like send them a
gift I've said listen I I sent
um
Michael Jordan my era Michael Jordan I
watched all the games right he was the
dude right he's my hero growing up too
yeah yeah so I wanted to meet Air Jordan
and I knew he had one part of his
charity back a decade ago I sent him a a
laptop and I cleared off all the icons
and I put one thing click here but I
sent them like the best
laptop at the time he clicked on it was
like a three minute video on how I
thought I could help him and I'd love to
help him with his charity and if there's
anything I could do let me know
90 days later I'm in Salt Lake City at
his house having dinner drinking a
bottle of Pinot Noir and he's telling me
about game six with the Utah Jazz like
my freaking dream come true but I didn't
go hey Michael if you promote it like I
did it in a way and here's the thing I
wasn't doing it as a game the guy gave
me so much entertainment just like
you're saying he did for you watching
that guy he revitalized basketball he
made it so cool he let you see the
underdog who got cut and caught in high
school and didn't make the team could go
on to be the best player in the world I
love the Underdog Story So I wrote the
book Underdog Advantage right like he
gave me so much I wasn't looking for
something I was saying thank you
and then all of a sudden I was there
right and this was a decade ago it
wasn't like I mean I was still doing
fairly well and out there but he had
never seen me before he had never seen
my stuff or so just just remember the
word reciprocity it'll change the way
you approach people and rule number six
the last one before some very special
bonus Clips is communicate better with
Brian Tracy I often get asked this
question Brian what is the key to
building successful relationships and my
answer is always the same communication
much of your success in life is going to
come from your ability to communicate
well with other people
successful people know how to
communicate and have taken a lot of time
to improve communication skills
social intelligence which is the ability
to interact with others is one of the
most respected intelligences in our
society
if you want to raise at your job you're
going to have to ask for one and be
prepared to communicate why you deserve
it
want to let someone know that they've
upset you or hurt you in some way
you're going to have to be able to
effectively communicate with them to
ensure they understand how they made you
feel
in communicating well with another
person time is the critical Factor
the value of a relationship can increase
for both of you and the other person
depending on the amount of time that you
invest
when you take the time to focus on the
important issues of a relationship you
open the channels of communication
and when you listen attentively calmly
quietly and with total attention you
demonstrate the respect you have for the
other person and you deepen the level of
trust between you effective
communication starts with being clear in
your own mind about what you want to say
then be clear when you deliver the
message saying it slowly and patiently
finally make sure that the other person
hears the message that you sent
when you communicate with another person
this is what happens
the first thing is you send a message
into the air in the form of words
then the words are received by the other
person who interprets them in their own
mind based on their own thoughts
feelings and so on after that the other
person formulates a response and sends
the response back you then receive the
response translate that into meaning and
significance and send back your response
it's easy to see how in the midst of all
that back and forth the original meaning
of your message could get lost based on
the other person's interpretation of
your words this is why it is so critical
to be clever and concise in how you word
things
if you give vague examples or don't
eloquently express your feelings you
leave an open opportunity for someone
else to analyze what you meant and
ultimately come to an incorrect
conclusion effective communication is
something that takes time to master and
which can change depending upon the
person who you are talking to the key is
to understand who you are speaking to
what's your ultimate goal of this
conversation is then determine the very
best route to get that message to the
individual
by consciously doing this you'll notice
that all of your relationships will
slowly begin to improve over time
when I started in this business I took
every single sale and it was because I
was so afraid that somebody would waste
the opportunity so if you have that fear
I understand where you're coming from
second when I had my first sale that was
not me I I just had this emotional
breakdown because I was like oh my God
this could actually happen and I promise
you if you haven't had it happen yet you
will when it does because you realize
that this business can actually work
without you and other people can make it
rain too right and then I'll tell you a
quick story that'll illustrate the next
point then would make so as I you know
hired some sales people now that first
sales person were they exceptional no
but they were able to get the job done
later on I had my first kind of like
killer
um and his name was Mario negretti and
he uh he came in
I don't know a year or two into the
business a year into the business and he
so quickly was able to assume the sales
role and to show you how laughable this
is he started and I was about to start
training him and some lady walked in the
door and I was like hey man like I can
take he's like no I'm good he's like go
do your thing he's like Fitness
Nutrition accountability okay I'll
figure it out and he ended up closing
this first lady who walked in the door
for a paid in full and I remember
walking in like completely dumpster I
was like he didn't even know what the
pitch was but she walked out giggling
happy so excited to start and would that
moment taught me was that
it is good to train sales people but
it's better to take great sales people
and then just point them in a direction
and so this has informed a lot of the
thinking that I have Around Talent in
general and I'll tell you a couple of
Frameworks that have informed this but
like if you look at Harvard Harvard
doesn't produce the smartest people they
select the smartest people and then they
put smart uh professors in front of them
but like the base level of intelligence
of everyone who's at Harvard is already
exceptionally high and so like even if
the teachers at Harvard were not
exceptional the students are and they
would be successful independent of that
because their selection is so ridiculous
right and so if we can think about our
own companies that way and especially if
you're in the service business like look
at the biggest service companies out
there like look at McKinsey look at Bain
look at BCG look at basically a lot of
the finance world is or service-based
businesses a lot of times right and
they're able to do that because they
create such a pool to select from that
they are able to skim for the best
talent right I heard this uh quote from
uh es true Kathy who's the founder of
Chick-fil-A you win the championship in
the draft and so it was such a belief
that they had about picking the right
people even more so than training and I
would say that I have moved in that
direction of a little bit more nature
than nurture when it comes to roles
specifically sales especially there are
certain characteristics about building
Rapport about having certain you know
Dynamics or energy whatever you want to
say that like Mario negretti when he
walked in he had all of these things and
he didn't even know the pitch but he won
that sale off of Just Pure Rapport and
so if I'm going to allocate the same
level of time to training somebody I
might as well start with somebody who
has a much higher base because I could
spend 10 hours to take someone from a
two to a four and a half or I could
spend the same 10 hours taking someone
from a six to a nine and the thing is
I'm also going to get more bang for my
buck in terms of my hours of training
with somebody who has natched a natural
Liberty for selling compared to somebody
who does not what's interesting about
this and this is just like my
observation is that you just have to be
willing to talk to more people in the
recruiting process I will say like from
a recruiting standpoint there's there's
two kind of things to look out for if
you're if you're if you cannot pay super
handsomely based on your price points
which you need to maybe fix later but
like if you can't pay super well for the
sales person then you need to look
harder and you'll need to interview more
people and you'll need to probably run
ads and use your network if you can pay
well the best sales people are already
employed and so it comes down to
recruiting those sales people from other
sales jobs ideally from companies just
like yours so that they already know a
lot of the things coming into it so it
decreases the ramp up time for them
because all we were really doing is
swapping products and the actual sales
cycle the type of sale is at a
transactional sales and a long sales at
a software sales is it a coaching
program set whatever it is right there's
so few variables that were changing that
they can immediately Jump and Go which
also allows you to make adjustment on
their proficient you faster and so as a
quick side note to this because this is
something that I've given a lot of
thought if you look at the top sales
people and sales trainers and this is
going to drive Point Drive home the
point that I was making earlier about it
being much of it being born all right is
that if you look at the top people who
are in the space you look at Jordan
Belfort right you look at Bradley you
look at and some people would would say
me in term from a selling perspective
all the guys that I know who have taught
sales were exceptional sales people day
one Bradley started selling cars when he
was 18 years old and was the top
salesman at 18 years old when he started
and he was like I just found something I
was really good at Jordan Belfort talks
about how he didn't know how to train
anybody in his book and then all of a
sudden he for the first time ever wrote
out a framework to explain the straight
line sale system which became his book
and all that kind of stuff but he up to
that point it was just what he naturally
did right and I can tell you in my
instance as well I'd already closed
thousands of deals before I even
consumed my first sales training and so
like I I do think that if we are
selecting sales people I think it's much
more about selection than it is about
training the training is to remind them
how good they are not necessarily to
make them good all right and this is
something that has shifted over time for
me specifically now if you're like well
I suck at sales you can absolutely put
way more time into yourself than a
business would recently put into an
employee all right like you have you all
the time so you can train you in all
your off hours and you're spending your
own time to invest in yourself but from
a return on investment perspective it's
the cost of finding a good salesperson
compared to the cost of training a bad
or mediocre sales person is
significantly lower it's much easier to
find the right people than it is to take
somebody and then make such a crazy
extensive training unless your entire
model is we just take on every single
person who walks in the door like 24
Hour Fitness has this model they take on
anybody who has a pulse and then they
put them through a ridiculous culling
process and then 10 of people make it in
the first 90 days The Matrix has you
now the Matrix to me is a simple
metaphor I don't actually believe that
we're living in the computer simulation
and even if we are I don't think that it
matters but what does matter is your
entire life is being lived by your brain
now what do I mean by that if you know a
guy named David Eagleman he wrote a book
called Incognito in the book Incognito
he makes one thing abundantly clear you
live in a virtual environment whether
you realize it or not that virtual
environment is created by the three
pounds of squishy material between your
ears
think about this
your brain never touches light
your brain is encased in a bone box in
total darkness
and yet it takes photons that fall on
the eye and turns it into
electrochemical stimulus and from that
it paints this environment it fakes the
sense of depth think about this for a
second there's not some little image of
this room projected into the back of my
mind this is all being turned into
electrochemical stimulus and my brain
then manufactures this environment
there's actually a dime spot blank part
in your field of vision where each optic
nerve connects to your eyes and yet you
have no experience of it that is
completely invisible to you even though
it's massive and it's dead center in
your eyes
the reason that you don't experience it
is because your brain fills it in your
brain makes a guess as to what would be
there and your brain is so good at
guessing and so good at presenting it as
if it were real that you have no sense
it is completely seamless to you
when I heard that I remember getting the
chills and setting the book down
and saying my brain is lying to me
that rat now the question becomes if
this is all made up if the sense of
distance between you and I is completely
manufactured by my brain and it's not
real
meaning what I see of it it's real
enough and that if I walk I'll hit you
at about the point that I'm expecting to
bump into you because my brain can
create that sense of distance
but it's doing it by translating those
signals it's manufacturing this space
so if that's true and my brain fills in
the gaps does my brain also have biases
and the answer is yes
Neuroscience has gone deep into how many
different biases that we have as humans
I'll give you one because this one is
profoundly impactful
you're more likely to believe something
negative than you are something positive
now think about how that can echo
through your life each of us has to
realize that all of the beliefs that we
have in our life
our choices
the scary part about the most important
beliefs in your life is most of them are
invisible I'm going to give you a couple
questions that will highlight invisible
beliefs that you have that are
controlling your life that are exactly
why I say the Matrix has you because
depending on how you answer these
questions will determine your life and
if you don't recognize something scary
in your own answers think about the
people that you love that you want to
help and you can't and you wonder why
the answer is almost certainly related
to how they answer some of these
questions number one this comes from
Einstein he said the most important
decision
the most important decision any human
being must make
is whether or not you live in a friendly
or a hostile universe
now we could have said realization but
he didn't he said decision you have to
decide because there is no empirical
truth you don't live in either a
friendly or a hostile Universe you
decide and that perception that
Viewpoint from which you judge
everything else that happens in your
life will be colored by whether or not
you think it is a universe that is
working for you or against you and it's
a choice but most people think of their
Viewpoint as being patently real as
being just objective and true and so
they never stop to question the fact
that they actually decided that at some
point either because their parents acted
in accordance with that it was either
hostile or friendly and they just absorb
that or their friends or the people that
they work with or whatever but somewhere
along the line they came to believe
that they live in either a friendly or a
hostile universe but you could change
right now right now you could make a
different decision and if you believe
that the world is working against you
right now you could choose to believe
that it's actually working for you and
in making a fundamentally new and
different assumption
it empowers you to move forward and this
is something that I will repeat in this
talk the reason that matters is human
beings do not invest energy in things
that they don't think will yield a
result many years ago
I read we're in Napoleon Hill
pointed out that the imagination is the
most marvelous
miraculous
inconceivably powerful force that the
world has ever known
and you know the average individual uses
the imagination if they use it at all
against themselves they imagine what
they don't want they imagine problems
coming
let's begin to use our imagination the
way God invented to be used it's the
greatest creative faculty that we
possess and we can build anything we
want with it I want you to wander around
your home or possibly your office and
take a look at all of the conveniences
that you have there
that you didn't have let's say two years
five years ten years ago 25 years ago
do you know that every one of them
without exception was first created
in the mind of one individual with their
imagination do you know you can use your
imagination to go into the future and
bring it into the present
that's what all highly successful people
do
they see where they want to go and then
they act like the person they want to
become
it was William James from Harvard's
advice
he says is the actor's technique act
like the person you want to become how
do you do that well you use your
imagination of course
you see it's a strange phenomena but the
greatest gift we've got
is used
very well
up till the ages of four or possibly
five
the little child
we always wonder what's going on in
their mind they're using their
imagination they're building wonderful
pictures in their mind but then they get
to school and Wham like that it comes to
an abrupt halt it's called not paying
attention
daydreaming well
what they were really doing was
exercising a phenomenal mental faculty
you see we can see here smell taste
touch therefore our physical benefit as
long as we're living in a physical body
and corresponding with the material
world we will use our sensory factors
but you know I have a couple of little
dogs at home that can hear see smell
taste and touch
we've got higher faculties you have
perception the will
memory intuition reason and Imagination
these marvelous tools
we can take our imagination and build an
image in our mind of how we want to live
block out what's going now don't let
your present results have anything to do
with this
just what you want and it's with your
imagination that you will build it
everything that we have the camera that
I'm speaking to right now was first
created in the mind of one individual
think of how our worlds changed
you see we were gifted with these higher
faculties
we're God's highest form of creation
we were created in God's image we were
given creative faculties to use
and you know they're only used by two or
three percent of the population
almost inconceivable that we people
would wander around with so much power
and potential
and squander it see the average person
literally tiptoes through life hoping
they make it safely to death
it's such a shame and it doesn't have to
be that way
we have giant corporations and little
weed creative departments the primary
reason for that is the average
individual
really does not believe that they're
creative
everyone's creative and no one is more
creative than another it's just that
some have chosen to use their creative
faculties to a greater degree than
others
[Music]
imagination your imagination
what do you want how do you really want
to live
build the picture in your mind there's a
power that is Flowing to and through you
a creative
unadulterated power
it can be photographed leaving your body
way back in the 30s Simeon curly in the
Russian photographer perfected a form of
Photography where you can actually
photograph a person's body and you will
see the energy glowing from them
well that energy flows into your mind
and it's the images you build in your
mind that's going to dictate the
vibration that this instrument are
living in is in and the vibration on a
conscious level is called feeling make
certain that you exercise your
imagination daily build beautiful images
in your mind of how you want to live and
then hold those pictures there and live
that way
the imagination
the greatest nation in the world the
imagination
you've got one it's a marvelous creative
tool
deals with the invisible side of your
personality
you see no one will ever really see you
they'll only see your body and they'll
see you the great work that you do make
certain that your work is great work and
if you keep your imagination alive keep
it active
you're going to have a phenomenal life
you know life can get better every day
and it will get better every day
through the proper use
of your imagination
what a wonderful idea it dawned on me
that
sometimes we don't have the right frames
when we're doing something
and we don't give things the right
meanings
and let me explain what I mean to you by
that
when we start something new
I think sometimes we forget
that anything that is new to our brain
may be exciting and may release dopamine
the neurochemical that he knows the
reward neurochemical
and we feel good because we've taken on
this new Endeavor whether it's a new
language whether it's retraining our
brain
whether it's starting to exercise or
eating better or committing to doing
something that's of benefit to us or
even stopping something
now the very nature of how our brain
works is that patterns that have been
repeated over you know months and years
are the dominant patterns in our brain
and therefore it's easier for our brain
to activate and follow through to
completion on those patterns it's like
having a you know highway system that's
been built it's easy for the cars to go
faster on the highway system well the
same thing is true with our brain and
the neural networks and Pathways so the
pathways are the easiest for the
chemicals to travel across and release
the
neurochemicals you know that make us
feel good or make us feel fearful or
make us feel apprehensive or doubtful
Etc are the ones that are the easiest
for our brain to activate and follow
through on okay part one
so that means that a new pattern meaning
stopping something or starting something
requires a little bit more of the
brain's energy and the Brain wants to
conserve energy so what is our brain
naturally going to do and the answer is
it's going to resist why because it
wants to preserve the energy that may be
required in case there's a saber-toothed
tiger that comes around from you know
the the woods to try and kill you so
we're in this energy conservation
mindset without even knowing it our
biology is geared towards doing things
that are easy for us not things that
require energy right glucose
so why am I sharing this with you well
as you're you know on your journey of
brain training upgrading your Knowledge
and Skills taking actions probably
different actions that you were taking
to achieve the results that you want
more and better results from of
um it requires you accessing higher
cortical functions and a higher level of
awareness is especially pay close
attention especially
when you feel resistance now I came out
here I still have my workout gloves on
because as I was doing uh some ab work
as I was doing you know some bench press
and flies for my chest one of the things
that dawned on me is most people do
things that they are comfortable doing
but in order to get stronger from a
cardiovascular perspective you have to
challenge yourself mix up your routines
you've got to go a little bit longer a
little bit harder
you know on the days that you want to
expand your capabilities so in the world
of uh you know doing weights for
strength training or building muscle
there are certain techniques to use in
certain strategies use including rest
right muscles build built in the rest
phase so let me explain what I'm talking
about I think you know where I'm going
with this
when I let's say do a bench press or fly
or I walk up a hill
the place where it's the hardest where
there's resistance where I want to quit
and stop and I'm breathing heavier I
just can't do another rep that's the
point of the growth
and the more you practice at that place
right the resistance the point of I want
to quit I can't do it anymore that is
how you expand your capacity resistance
happens
when you're at the edges of Your
Capacity now it could be mental edges
emotional edges physical edges Financial
edges and how does it show up it shows
up as stress
right stress so stress happens when your
current capacity let me repeat
stress happens when your current
capacity exceeds
the demand
your current capacity exceeds the demand
so how do you increase demand I'm sorry
how do you increase capacity well you
feel the edges and go one more you feel
the tension and keep doing it you feel
the desire to quit but then you do as
much as you can and as you do as much as
you can you get mentally stronger
physically stronger emotionally stronger
so when I feel like let's say quitting I
just say just a little bit more when I
don't feel like it I say I know but just
do a little bit why because I want to
override my natural and your natural
propensity to want to quit to want to
stop it's natural
but I don't want to be natural I want to
be Supernatural I don't want to be
ordinary I want to be extraordinary and
that's that little extra does that make
sense so as you're training your brain
as you have videos to watch upgrade your
Knowledge and Skills as you have events
to attend you know to to connect to to
listen to learn to expand
if you catch yourself thinking or
feeling I don't feel like it I'm too
tired not today tomorrow that's the
language okay that the brain uses the
rationalizations the rational lies that
your brain my brain everybody's brain
uses to keep you in your comfort zone
well guess what everything you want
financially in your relationship
health-wise is just outside your comfort
zone if you keep challenging and
expanding your mental emotional physical
spiritual Financial Comfort zones you
expand as a human being and you start
fulfilling more of your potential than
standing on the edge of it hoping and
praying and wishing that you can have
greater better results you are the
product of the five people that you
spend the most time with you've heard
that before you know it's important and
the reason why it's so true is because
of a concept in Persuasion in that
whoever is more confident wins whoever
is more confident in their opinion in on
something in their habits on something
is the one who wins and persuades and
influences other people to join them
even without having to say anything just
somebody being so confident in their own
negativity in their own world and their
own bad habits without even telling you
anything you will naturally pick up on
that thing and dive down that same
negative rabbit hole with them and and
that that's the fight because if you are
around people who are negative who have
the bad habits that you don't want to
have anymore it's not that it's
impossible but you're making it a lot
more challenged on yourself to be able
to pull yourself out of the hole you are
the result of the five people that you
spend the most time with so let's say
you want to work out you want to work
out you want to be healthy this is the
year you want to lose weight you want to
be in the best shape of your life
amazing right
but it's a new habit and this is the
problem at the very beginning of a new
habit if we go back to the concept of
persuasion
you don't have a lot of persuasion over
yourself yet you don't have a lot of
influence over yourself yet on this
habit because it's so new
so it's easy to get pulled in a million
different directions you're looking for
any possible reason why not to do it and
if you have a goal to go to the gym
every day or you have a goal to eat
healthy today and then you see your
friends around you just diving in on Big
Macs and lying on the couch and
complaining and being negative
you can fight that
but at some point that fight starts to
wear down on you and your resolve isn't
strong enough yet because it's too new a
habit and so it's likely to happen is
you're gonna go join them because they
are more confident in their negative
approach than you are in the positive
approach they have such a history with
the bad habit
that didn't influence you to go back
down that negative path I remember
hanging out with a very popular YouTuber
and he was asking well how do I grow
even to the next step and I'm I love how
consistent you are he's talking about my
channel how consistent I was and when I
was
with him over dinner
one of the things that I struggled with
was when I travel I usually let my diet
go you know I'm traveling having fun I
don't have my usual routine and so not
that I would just smash Doritos down my
face but I would just eat whatever and
he was at a restaurant with me and he
was eating really clean he had a fish
and salad and no dressing and just
really really clean and was waking up
the next day he was gonna go for a run
some of those habits are what I do here
when I'm at home but I don't do it when
I travel and so here he was admiring how
consistent I was on making videos and
having however many thousands of videos
now on the channel and I was admiring
how consistent he was in his eating
healthy and his working out now what
would happen if we started to hang out
more
if we started to hang out more and we
look at those two things the consistency
on making videos and the staying healthy
on the consistency of making videos I am
so
it's just part of me now I'm so
confident in my making videos and that I
have to get it done that even if he was
lying on the couch all day not that he
would but even if he was he wouldn't
negatively influence me so I would suck
him to making more videos he would be
making more videos as a result of
hanging out with me it would just
naturally happen without me even saying
anything to him because here's what
would happen he might be on the couch he
might be getting this track he might be
doing something else I said okay man I
gotta go make videos and by me going off
and making videos it will motivate him
to go make more videos I don't have to
say anything your actions speak way
louder than your words don't tell
somebody to go do something you want to
influence and persuade them go do the
thing and they'll see you doing it now
it's in their environment and it's gonna
suck them in so if we hung up together
he would be more consistent on the
content
on the other hand if we hung out
together consistently
I would get healthier with my my travel
diet if I traveled every time with him
then we would likely eat at more healthy
restaurants he would likely be working
out every morning I would likely join
him on some of those he would just
pull me towards being a healthier
traveler compared to what I am now
because he is so confident in that habit
that he's trying to build and so where
we struggle as entrepreneurs is we're
trying to build these new habits we're
trying to pull ourselves up to a better
brighter future better place more proud
of ourselves but we're still stuck with
the people around us who are in a
negative environment who want to stay
stuck who just complain about where they
are instead of actually trying to build
something better for themselves so if
that remains your friend's Circle in the
next five years it's going to be really
really challenging for you to get to the
place where you want to be okay well
that's that's great Evan how do I change
it I mean I don't want to just leave my
friends I don't even know where to get
new friends how do I start this process
there are three big strategies I want to
give you that I think will really really
help first off you don't have to go off
and tell all your friends hey you guys
suck I'm better than you I don't want to
hang out with you anymore
right so step one is just do an audit
just do an audit of your friends just do
an audit of the five people that you
spend the most time with just think
about it in the past two months who have
you spent the most time with and then
how many of them make you feel better
about yourself where you leave them
feeling more bold more confident more
excited for your life more ready to go
and take on the big challenges that are
ahead of you and hand me them make you
feel worse how many of them you have to
go home and have a nap or how many of
them you just feel drained as a result
of talking to them not that they're bad
people they're just in a lot of pain
right again I don't think that there are
toxic people I just think that they're
in a lot of pain and and hurt people
hurt people right so if you're not
strong enough yet to influence them
they're gonna suck you down so step one
is to do an audit of your friends step
two is to limit access to the people who
are making you feel worse about yourself
again it doesn't mean you have to go and
tell them that they suck just just stop
spending time together
as you spend less time together you will
find that the relationship just kind of
Fizzles away you don't have to have some
big conversation just kind of access
spend less time go out once a month
instead of once a week call them less
frequently stop doing things together
you'll just notice that as you spend
less time together
you stop getting influenced so
negatively people are so afraid of
breaking off a friendship because you
think you have to have this really tough
conversation you don't you don't you
just have to spend less time with them
just look at your calendar see how often
you usually spend and your goal for next
month is to spend half the amount of
time or a quarter of the amount of time
that you spent with them as last month
that's it that's step two it doesn't
have to be some big break doesn't have
to be crazy scary it doesn't have to be
overwhelming and massively painful step
three is it gonna be to fill the void so
if you stop spending time with people
two things happen one you get a this
void it's like well who do I spend time
with now I have this extra time in my
calendar I've got these blocks and the
other thing is you start to feel lonely
you know if you don't have that friend
circle around you anymore it's easy to
feel lonely which is maybe even worse
than spending time with them at least
you have some kind of connection we're
settling for just okay relationships
because we crave the connection because
you just want to have somebody around
you because it's better to be with that
person than it is to be alone
and that's the biggest fear is that
you're just gonna end up alone that
you'll never find anybody even in
romantic relationships but also in your
friendships because it can be harder as
you get older to join friend circles to
make new friends is why a lot of people
are still stuck with the same friends
they had in high school and University
because they never actually went to go
out and search for new friends because
it's so afraid that you're gonna be
stuck alone so in that vacuum in that
void in that hole in your calendar now
what are you gonna do well the goal is
to now meet new people and you don't
have to treat it like it's dating it's a
relationship you just go off to the
events and the and the people that you
feel like you might have a connection to
so I'm introverted I'm shy I am not a
people person I hate networking events I
hate small talk
and so how I would do it if you're
extroverted it's super easy just go and
go to the events and hang out and say hi
and say hi I'm Evan good to meet you I
would never I never go up to anybody and
say hi I'm Evan it's great to meet you
what do you do I just I never do that
um so the easy way to do it is think
about the clubs the activities and the
events that are really interesting for
you that it's a lot more natural for you
to have a conversation about so if there
was just a business networking meeting I
would hate that I hate that kind of
stuff where you have to explain what it
is that you do and they don't really
care or interested in but finding common
Hobbies
so for me
I'll pick entrepreneurship I would pick
League of Legends I would pick salsa
dancing and signing into Minecraft so
maybe maybe some Minecraft I would pick
something in those four areas where I
could easily connect with people that it
doesn't feel like a chore to talk about
because I love that topic
as a quick example
um I was on an airplane and I was flying
to Brighton burchard's event in Puerto
Rico and so I was I was one of two
external speakers coming in to speak at
the event and this is his high level
Mastermind these are people who are
pain Thirty to fifty thousand dollars to
be in that room
and I'm flying down there and I you know
I'm in business class there's only one
person next to me and he's trying to
strike up a conversation and I I just I
just don't like it it's like so where
are you going like well we're going to
Puerto Rico like where are you coming
from I'm from Toronto and he was coming
up from Vancouver and I just I hate the
small talk right I hate the small talk
and so I think he kind of noticed after
a couple tries that I wasn't really
interested in talking to him I didn't
mean to be rude I just it doesn't
fulfill me I'd rather just be by myself
and alone and focus on what I need to
talk about and so we're flying down
there
and I don't really know why he's going
or what you know what he's going for
what his business is in Puerto Rico if
he's speaking if he's got an event what
so we don't really talk for the rest of
the way not anything root just we're in
our own world
I get there and get in my uh my taxi or
Uber or whatever and drive to the hotel
where we're staying
and as I'm checking in guess who shows
up right behind me
right next to me on the counter the same
guy that I spent all this time now just
sitting next to not talking to on the
airplane
and he said hey you're here too it's
like and as soon as I knew that he was
here for Brendan burchard's event it's
like yeah man are you here too oh my God
what's your business
as soon as I found out that he was an
entrepreneur it's it's way easier to
have a connection and so we spent a
little more time there chatting spent a
couple a couple of moments over the over
the course of the conference as well but
it's so much easier to make connections
when you have a joint interest right if
I know you're an entrepreneur or I know
you care about League of Legends or
Minecraft or salsa dancing if I know any
of those things we are instantly going
to be friends and have something to talk
about
but if you're just a normal human who
maybe I don't know anything about then
it's a lot more difficult so
because you have this vacuum and you
don't know who to connect with and you
want to feel that connection and
belonging with a group
don't let that hole and that pain drag
you back to the circle that you know
doesn't ultimately support you and look
for the events that are exciting for you
to go to for the clubs for the
activities that you are generally like
oh that'd be so cool to be able to go
there and you'll end up meeting
like-minded people and that becomes your
new friend Circle and when that happens
when you hold on to good people like
that you actually stop even caring that
some of the people
you know I've kind of drifted or you've
you've let go of at some point instead
of spending once a month with them now
maybe it's once a year just catching up
or maybe you don't talk again not again
because you've had some conversation and
they hate you you've just Grown Apart
and the last time you spend with
somebody the more you're gonna grow
apart you are the product of the five
people that you hang out with the most
you've heard it before you'll hear it
again when is the time to actually take
the action do the audit of your friend's
Circle do they make you feel better
about yourself or Worse about yourself
stop spend as much time with the people
that make you feel worse about yourself
and then fill the void fill the vacuum
with people who lift you up by going to
events and clubs and activities that you
genuinely care about it's not just a
strategy to make connections but you
love being there you will meet some
amazing like-minded people every day of
Our Lives we live in a world that is
incredibly complex and you have to
remember we all have a two million year
old brain
and it's not designed to make you happy
it's designed to make you survive
so it's always looking for what's wrong
so why would we allow this to be because
it's just a bad habit and so we need a
daily practice and so I want to show you
how I do this for me and I want you to
create your own system based on it this
mind serves me I don't negotiate with it
remember I told you I don't say well
I'll do this well maybe we can do it
maybe we'll jump in the water now it's
like it knows I'm not here to negotiate
when I say it we do it
that's what we want to train ourselves
to do today whenever you want to make a
change or improve something
the first place you want to prove it is
in your mental emotional state
if you do something from a pissed off
state from an exhausted state from a
frustrated state from a weak state it
won't matter what you do the thoughts
are weak when you're in a weak place the
actions are weak so the first thing
we're going to do is I'm going to show
you a simple breathing pattern and the
breathing pattern if you're familiar
with yogas like Breath of Fire similar
to Breath of Fire and it's a movement
here what it's going to look like is
this you're going to sit up in your
chair with energy we're going to raise
our hands up as we take the air in and
then you're going to blow it out
only going to blow it out your nose and
we're going to do that over and over
again for 30 breaths you're going to do
this with your eyes closed then you're
going to drop your hands down Palms up
on your weight on your legs and you're
just going to feel whatever you feel you
might notice some tingling
you might notice a sense of peace
it might just feel relaxed and then
we'll do another three sets of ten
another 30 we'll relax and then another
so we'll do three sets of 30. three sets
of ten ten ten ten ten ten ten ten with
a break between them when you're done
with that you're ready to Prime because
it puts you in state priming is three
actions it's done in ten minutes you can
do more than ten and many of you will
enjoy it so much you'll go longer but
the reason I do 10 minutes of priming is
I wanted to come up with a daily
discipline there was no excuse not to do
if you don't have 10 minutes for
your life you don't have a life so what
we're gonna do is we're gonna do our
three sets of ten three sets of ten
three sets of ten then with our eyes
closed the first three and a third
minutes of the ten minutes is we're
going to focus on three experiences in
our life that we can feel deeply
grateful for three of them and we're not
going to think I'm like oh this this
we're gonna take them one at a time
spend about a minute each and step into
that moment in your life that you could
feel grateful for it could be a little
thing or a big thing it doesn't matter
what matters is that you go there you
know if I ask you what's it likes to me
on a roller coaster and you remember
time when you're in a roller coaster and
you picture yourself in a roller coaster
over there
you're going to give me a very different
feedback than if I get you to imagine
the moment you were going over the edge
and you're in the front seat
then you're going to show me a different
result you want your gratitude to be in
the front seat not an intellectual
gratitude out there so I take three
minutes
a minute each I come up with something
different every time I think of a moment
that I could feel so grateful for a
blessed moment a beautiful moment a
loving moment a sacred moment and I step
in and feel it and flood myself with the
Gratitude gratitude is the antidote to
the two emotions that mess up most
people's lives what are they anger and
what fear those are the two biggest
you cannot be grateful and angry
simultaneously that's the beauty of it
it's the antidote to anger you can't be
fearful and grateful simultaneously so
the more you cultivate and Prime
yourself for gratitude the more you can
push through anger and fear very quickly
and by the way when I do it
I usually pick two strong ones and then
I pick something really simple and I
make myself really feel the Gratitude
like the wind on my face or the smell of
the ocean if I'm doing it outside by my
house or the look on one of my
children's faces and I'll just fill that
up and the reason is
if all you do is get grateful about big
things you're going to miss most of life
after we do our breathing step one of
the three steps first the breathing then
the three steps one gratitude three
minutes roughly a minute each three
different moments you can feel grateful
for and feel it enjoy it savor it live
in it next three in the third minutes
second piece we're gonna do is you're
gonna feel the energy in you and do a
prayer or a blessing now I know many of
you are not religious I'm not suggesting
you need to be
but almost all of us know there's a
power in love
you know if God was love and we didn't
come up with all the other names for God
you wouldn't have much argument between
people so imagine that what you're going
to do is Imagine uh energy of God the
universe whatever you want to imagine
coming down into you like a white light
and breathing it down in through your
body down your legs into the Earth and
then coming back up and out again so
it's
and then comes back up
and you don't have to do this with your
hands but I'm trying to show you what
the feeling is and while you're doing
this what you're going to do during
those three minutes is you're going to
give thanks it's like a prayer saying
heal my body my mind my emotions
strengthen me make me the best I can be
strengthen my love my passion my courage
whatever it is that you value in
yourself and you feel that happening of
the three minutes I do that for about a
minute and a half and the other minute
half I then take that energy through me
and I send it in a circle around to my
children to my family to my friends to
my co-workers to my associates to my
partners to the people I meet in the
street to my clients and so it's taking
the energy and now you might sound like
Lulu stuff but the idea of allowing your
nervous system to heal and strengthen
just the focus of that alone for you is
strong and sending to others as well so
you can think it's all but try
it and decide based on the experience if
you do it a while I think you're going
to find it'll deepen that sense of
gratitude because it becomes not only
gratitude but healing is strengthening
and a gift to those you love the last
three minutes I call three to thrive
you're going to think of three things
that you really want to accomplish or
achieve but instead of like hoping it
happens or thinking about it happening
you're going to step in your mind and
experience it as if it's done you're
going to see it or feel it breathe it
celebrate it like you've already
achieved the goal what you're doing is
training your reticular activating
system and we talked about this the
other day the part of your brain that
notices things when you did you know
before you bought that car outfit you
never noticed them now you buy that car
outfit those cars and outfits are
everywhere how come because your Ras now
that your own one says this is important
I need to pay attention to this well
when you get clear what you want and you
see it as done and feel it and create it
in your mind in your heart and you
celebrate it there's a sense of
certainty than there's your body and
your reticular activated system starts
to go to work on making it happen so you
spend a minute at each one of those so
basically three minutes each three and
third minutes each and we're done and
one of the things that will help you to
do the work to create the things that
you want in your life
is it will help you if you train your
mind
to start spotting evidence as you're
doing the work as you're going through
your day it will help you if you train
your mind to start scanning the world
and spotting evidence that yes indeed
the world is sending you positive
signals that things are going to work
out now why is it important to train
your mind to help you get what you want
well the reason why is because if you
get into a negative mindset if you start
thinking
this business is never going to work why
even bother I'm never going to meet
anybody it's nothing but losers out
there look at all these idiots on hinge
why the hell should I keep doing this if
you allow your mind to start to rest in
a pessimistic negative protective scared
and doubtful stance your mind will
continue to show you reasons why there's
nobody on hinged worth talking to your
mind will continue to show you all the
reasons why you will never make it in
business your mind will continue to show
you all the reasons why you're never
going to lose that weight and be able to
tuck in your shirt as my friend Corinne
Crabtree always talks about that
transformational moment and when your
mind goes negative your mind starts to
scan the world and will show you more
reasons to stop and the power of
training your mind to spot positive
signs is very simple the power is that
your mind will start to show you reasons
to keep going your mind will help you
take the step your mind will encourage
you to feel optimistic to feel empowered
just like you woke up today on a Tuesday
and it was February 22nd 2022 and those
numbers are lining up and that makes you
in your heart and soul go whoa something
cool could happen today like that
only happens like once in my lifetime
those numbers are going to line up like
that today is a really cool day let's go
do something with this you could create
that kind of attitude every single
freaking day of your life you could if
you train your mind and if you start
taking action and training your mind is
the key piece that we're going to talk
about
so for those of you that have read the
high five habit one of the things that I
talk about a lot is every single day
find a naturally occurring heart-shaped
object in the world it could be a stone
it could be a leaf it could be a cloud
it could be a shape in your coffee hey
Chris if we've got anything around here
that looks like a heart hand it to me
and the reason why I love telling you to
start playing a game with yourself well
you start your day going mind brain show
me some heart oh what is this come here
dog treat oh my God it's a dog treat
look at this guys
what shape is that
that right there is a harp
there we go check that out
if you say brain mind show me a heart
today guess what's going to happen that
damn dog biscuit it's gonna show it's
gonna you're gonna be like there's a
heart you're gonna look out at the sky
and you're gonna see a heart shape oh
right there in the mountains there's a
heart shape in the mountains in southern
Vermont you're going to see it in the
clouds what you're doing when you tell
your mind what's important to you is
you're telling your mind and the filter
in your brain to change in real time and
allow into your consciousness
what's important to you and if you want
to see hearts by God those damn dog
treats are going to start looking like
hearts everybody that's how you train
your mind it's freaking incredible and
if you want to see evidence of this
follow me on social media if you follow
me Mel Robbins on social media you will
see every day I am reposting your
stories of finding heart shapes around
the world now why is this important well
it's important because it's a simple way
to prove to you that your mind changes
in real time that if you get serious
about becoming more positive and
optimistic and encouraging of yourself
if you get serious about saying this I
don't want to see all the reasons why
I'm unhappy I don't want to see
everybody else in the world that's
launched a business or that's lost
weight and is healthy or that has a
really good marriage or relationship and
I don't want to see that and and have my
mind process it as evidence that it's
never going gonna happen for me I want
my mind to reprogram itself and see
other people's businesses and see other
people getting healthy and see other
people in relationships and I want my
mind to say yeah if they can do it I can
do it that's evidence if that person can
get healthy so can I if that person can
find somebody on hinge so can I if that
person can reconcile with their child so
can I other people can become evidence
that you can have it too right now your
mind is so up from your past that
when you see what other people have and
you don't have it you can't actually
translate it through a negative mind and
and see that that's evidence that you're
going to win you see it like oh somebody
already stole what I wanted that sucks
and so what I want to start to open your
mind to is that you have the power to
train your mind
to filter the world differently just
like you woke up and you saw the date
today 2 22 22 and your brain saw that
was like whoa this is a once in a
lifetime day everybody
you are never going to have another day
that lines up like this ever
what are you going to do with this day
your mind already interpreted this as
wow
something cool could happen
and if you tell yourself something
amazing is going to happen today
something will because you're going to
be looking for it I swear to God
something will something will if you
want to see the good all around you you
got to tell your mind you want to see
the good and this just isn't a bunch of
horsesh everybody this isn't toxic
positivity there is a filter in your
brain called the reticular activating
system
the reticular activating system I call
it the RAS I like to think about it like
a giant hair net on your head and this
Ras sits over your brain I'm probably
getting this wrong I'm not a
neuroscientist I could give about
getting it right I just need you to know
the basics here so that you can apply it
to your life okay you don't need a PhD
to use the science that super smart
people have been working really hard on
in order to apply it to your life that's
what I'm here for in your life I'm here
to translate this stuff into simple
believable and actionable things that
you can do to take all this super cool
stuff that people are researching and
apply it to your normal person's
everyday life to help you change from
the inside out and one of the coolest
things that you have at your disposal is
you have a whole system in your body
that you can train and change and one of
those things that you can train and
change that is impacted by that real
that word you're hearing a lot of
neuroplasticity that just means that
things are able to twist and bend and
change and you're able to learn new
things for as long as you're alive as
long as you're breathing everybody you
got a chance to change the way that you
think as long as you are breathing you
got a chance to change from the inside
out how you experience your life as long
as you are still here watching me people
you got a chance to create a new
experience in your life and one of the
things that helps a lot is understanding
that right now all of the bullsh from
your past has jammed the filter in your
mind body and spirit the reticular
activating system and it is clouding
your ability to look at the world around
you and see hearts remember this dog
treat hearts look at that there's a
heart right there
because you made it this far in a video
I want to celebrate you most people
start and don't finish most people never
actually follow through most people say
they want something but they don't ever
do the work to actually get it but
you're different you are special believe
Nation you made it here all the way to
the end and I love you so it's a special
celebration if you put a hashtag believe
down in the comments Below on this video
I will showcase you and celebrate you
somewhere on the screen in a future
video because you are awesome if you
want to learn how to grow your network
check the video right there next to me I
think you'll love it continue to believe
and I'll see you there audience
interaction is always the best you know
like most people get up there and just
speak and speak and speak and speak and
it's never as personal as it could be so
as much as possible I love defaulting to
as much q a as possible